[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Київ,
Наддніпрянщина]
Коли я тільки вступила в консерваторію київську,
[Сусана Джамаладінова (Джамала)
співачка]
я вступила на клас оперного вокалу.
І було так смішно, що...
Був такий екзамен як колоквіум.
Він включає в себе
все, що завгодно.
Тобто можуть спитати з музики, з літератури,
з культури — тобто все, що завгодно.
І кажуть там:
«А, на цьому екзамені завжди валять,
якщо не хочуть взяти».
Я заспівала спеціальність
на «відмінно».
Потім був колоквіум,
і там у мене спитали:
«Ану скажи, будь ласка, як буде кримськотатарською «Я тебе люблю?»
Я така: «Хмм».
Для мене це означало:
«Oкей, вони мене беруть».
Я сказала, звичайно:
«Men seni sevem (Мен сені севем)».
Така була до мене якась
нотка екзотики.
Типу вона ж — кримська татарка,
і така...
З одного боку,
тоді мене це дуже надихало,
і я ходила така вся:
знаєте, я тут — екзотика.
А потім все ж таки
десь це мене зачіпляло,
ображало. Чому?
Я така, як ви.
Я — українка.
Давним-давно у Кримського муфтіяту
було представництво тут, на материковій Україні,
це в документах зафіксовано,
[Айдер Рустамов,
муфтій Духовного управління мусульман АР Крим
на материковій частині України]
саме на Нивках.
Отак от. Ми орендували цю будівлю.
Довго шукали.
Я сам з Криму, кримський татарин.
Батьки мої також з Криму,
але вони народилися вже в депортації.
Батько народився в Середній Азії.
я також народився в Середній Азії.
Але мій дідусь, моя бабуся,
всі вони народилися в Криму.
Крим — це Україна.
Ми тут почуваємося вільно.
Це по-перше і це найвагоміше.
Люди, які виїжджають сюди на материк,
вони кажуть:
«О, тут дихається інакше»,
Розумієте?
Перша ціль — це займатися духовністю
і релігійною діяльністю,
Тобто, щоб тут на материку,
ті кримські татари,
які вимушено покинули свою
батьківщину,
щоб вони якось зберегли свою ідентичність
релігійну, культурну.
Власне, вся наша діяльність
на це спрямована.
Так сталось, що кримські татари є
більш світськими,
аніж більшість інших мусульман світу.
Тому я, відповідно, сьогодні вдягнена
в джинси, в чоловічий піджак.
[Таміла Ташева,
правозахисниця, співзасновниця «КримSOS»]
У мене таке життя,
і це абсолютно нормально для
кримського татарина
або кримської татарки,
які живуть в сучасному ХХІ столітті.
Алейкум селям!
Так, я пам'ятаю Вас, звісно.
Дуже важливо, що у кримських татар
немає стигматизації:
ти «правильний» або «неправильний»
кримський татарин.
Є жінки, які навіть вдягаючи хіджаб,
вони все одно працюють,
вони ходять на роботу.
У нас є журналістки, які одягають хіджаб.
Є спортсменки, художниці, дизайнерки,
які, одягаючи хіджаб,
все одно є активними учасницями
суспільного життя.
Єдиною консолідованою
серйозною політичною силою в Криму
проукраїнською силою в Криму були
кримські татари завжди.
Перший прапор над Сімферополем,
прапор України,
підняв кримський татарин насправді.
Зараз підійду.
Доброго дня.
Як Ваші справи?
Нічого, все нормально. У вас?
У нас все добре.
Все добре?
Почало дощити, людей поменшало?
Так, трошки вже пішли.
[Ескендер Буджуров,
засновник кримськотатарського кафе «Софра»]
Коли у Криму сталося те,
що сталося,
ми вирішили звідти виїхати
і відкрити тут...
А тут треба було виживати!
А як виживати?
Треба створювати роботу.
Син у мене тоді ще був студентом
Завершував якраз навчання тоді.
Жив тут, в Києві, і казав: «Тато, я так хочу чебуреків!».
А я йому: «У всьому Києві що, немає чебуреків?»
Десь він купував чебуреки і казав:
«Тату, тут немає нічого спільного
із тими чебуреками,
із справжніми чебуреками».
Та і якось воно зачепилося.
А потім, коли ми вирішили їхати сюди,
буквально за місяць-два,
кажу: «А давай от чебуреки будемо...
відкриємо такий заклад,
де ми будемо робити,
смажити чебуреки справжні.
Я думаю, киянам сподобається».
Для мене Україна —
це батьківщина.
Так, я не народилась тут.
Але я вважаю,
що мої батьки повернулися
на батьківщину своїх пращурів.
Мій батько повернувся саме в те місто,
звідки походив весь рід Джамаладінових.
Ми повернулися.
Як я завжди кажу,
це не новина для вас,
що Крим — це Україна.
Я вважаю, що для мене
це — батьківщина.
І неповторна, переможниця
пісенного конкурсу «Євробачення»...
Неймовірна, фантастична,
справжній голос Криму, України.
Зустрічайте — Джамала!
♪ Я знайду, ♪
♪ я знайду свій шлях додому, ♪
♪ хоч важко буде йти ♪
♪ крізь спогадів шалену втому, ♪
♪ там буде затишно і світло. ♪
♪ Птахи в долонях, ♪
♪ неначе в сні, ♪
♪ мене чекає шлях додому, ♪
♪ батьківський погляд, ♪
♪ камені стіни ♪
♪ вже як норма ♪
♪ мого життя. ♪
♪ Шлях додому, додому, додому... ♪
У мене є одна тільки мрія,
яка стосується всіх нас.
Щоб Крим був Україною,
щоб я могла поїхати додому зі своїм сином.
І... Так.
♪ Шлях, шлях, шлях додому... ♪
[Кримські татари — корінний народ України, який тричі пережив вигнання у батьківщини:]
[у ХVIII ст. Кримське ханство
захопила Російська імперія,]
[у 1944 році радянська влада депортувала
їх у Центральну Азію]
[і вже у 2014 році Російська Федерація
анексувала Крим.]
[Сьогодні серед українських політв'язнів, яких досі не звільнили — чимало кримських татар.]
[Кримці активно борються за свої права та свободи, поєднують релігійне та світське життя,]
[зберігають і показують свою багату культуру світові та мріють повернутися до Криму.]
Дякую!
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Марія Теребус, Микола Носок]
[У відео використано аудіотрек Jamala
«Шлях додому»]
[Субтитрувальниця
Валерія Діденко]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки USAID]